what you do this to me I guess no one
told you life was gonna be this way
cooker spaghetti bolognaise play every
night and I start with the onions and I
worked my way through and there was a
very helpful lady a couple of rows back
he's been the entire show commenting on
every ingredient so I'd get the onions
out start chopping she cooked oh my god
there's onions lady what's your name
Jessica Jessica conclu creative here
Jessica for then
she's so sweet she's French
she's adorable atomic she's French she
said did she say like Pathan she's pause
[Music]
[Applause]
Samantha well you promise about that New
Zealand New Zealand there's always one
here are you traveling I'm living here
at the moment and what do you do I'm on
a working visa many okay I didn't think
you were working illegally but thanks
okay do you have an MC name no I don't
click fortune no this is it John oh I
can't think of it can you think of an MC
name for him Johnny be good alright so
you want some beats alright love some
okay so let's have some beats what's
quite quite chilly
okay chilling out at home watching BBC
when my sweet lady said to me yo fazz a
dude I got to see she never said that
so here we are now from across the pond
to watch Graham Norton get it on Graham
Norton
[Music]
okay to our friends meet after a long
time they're old school friends and they
talk about the past and have you seen
these how do you see someone he said oh
yes I saw Maria funnily enough I saw
Maria last week who's Maria you remember
Maria she was some very slim very
flat-chested you remember not very
pretty
oh yes I remember her yes well I saw her
and she is looking live is ah why she
had pleasure you know breast enlargement
no she's got 31 arthritis
[Applause]
she's like this
he's got his best nurses got terrible
arthritis
oh it sounds like English so how many
women here so shout out how many women
here I've read the books okay and how
many men have read the books
did you enjoy them now is this the one
about your partner Sarah yes and is she
here
there she is oh heas for us and
beautiful saris this is Sarah and Martin
it's almost like a love rap yeah you
both do good beats okay
this is Rapada her name is Sarah a lot
of people think I'm her carer
[Applause]
okay fair I'm so sorry father
crazy we made some line now switch ever
that's just fine
she boutiques me and gives me credit and
loves my nickname to time her ferret
she's always willing and never says no
now I'm a gazer I choose my home
[Applause]
being eventually on the cards really you
are this is cheap and tacky this is all
for this like the Jeremy Kyle show
unless you wanted that you can do it if
you want to
[Applause]
me like you needed my car deep breath
Nicole you're my best friend you're the
other half of me I'll just go get
something on my sock
[Applause]
and therefore I can see a tear coming I
can see it
[Music]
[Applause]
will you marry me yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
take that
it's definitely there yeah that was that
was a tough one out of nowhere now one
of the people who sadly didn't make it
was of course relate husband Khal Drogo